anthony blinken un nuevo apoyo para el
proceso de paz en colombia el
departamento de estado de eeuu se
eliminó a las farc de su lista negra de
grupos terroristas donde figuraba desde
1997 las farc ahora convertidas en el
partido político comunes han estado
lidiando con bloqueos financieros además
de la prohibición de entrada a eeuu esta
decisión significa una nueva oportunidad
es la posibilidad de que el proceso de
reincorporación socioeconómica y
política pueda avanzar en mejores
comisiones el beneplácito de eeuu llega
una semana después del quinto
aniversario de la firma de paz cuando el
secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres visitó colombia a un mundo de
decisiones geopolíticas
guerras interminables y multiplicación
de conflictos
colombia e inicia hoy un mensaje claro
es hora de vestirse en la paz
el departamento de estado no eliminará
cargos previos por narcotráfico y otros
crímenes relacionados con el firmantes e
incluyó a las disidencias de las farc
lideradas por gentil duarte que desertó
durante las conversaciones de paz e iván
márquez que lo hizo dos años después
este último cuestionó los acuerdos el
lunes para medios locales el estado
viola al principio en toda negociación
queremos un gobierno que se la juegue
todas por la paz completa
pese a estas decepciones el 95 por
ciento de los 13.000 firmantes de paz se
han desmovilizado un compromiso que gana
adeptos como eeuu en este caso para
seguir llevando adelante la
implementación de la paz